you may have heard some stories uh in uh  the press uh that the uh tennis player  nick curios uh is to face court uh next  month over an assault allegation there  were allegations that he may have  assaulted  a partner well we now have a statement  from the police in canberra in australia  saying that they can confirm that a 27  year old watson man is scheduled to face  the act magistrates court on the 2nd of  august in relation to one charge of  common assault following an incident in  december 2021 but it is not yet clear  whether this does refer to an allegation  of assault against his ex-girlfriend uh  we at sky are chasing comment from his  lawyers or spokespeople on that but  it does appear that police in australia  are confirming that a 27 year old watson  man who we believe to be nick kirk  kyrgios is to face court  next month over an assault allegation